one of the most powerful ideas in deep
learning is that sometimes we can take
the knowledge the new network has
learned from one toss and apply that
knowledge to a separate task so for
example maybe kind of a new network
learn to recognize objects like cats and
then use that knowledge or use part of
that knowledge to help you do a better
job reading x-ray scans this is called
transfer learning let's take a look
let's say you've trained in your network
on image recognition so you first take a
neural network and train it on XY pairs
where X is an image and Y is some object
in the image as a cat or a dog or bird
or something else if you want to take
this new network and a gap or we say
transfer what is learn to a different
tasks such as radiology diagnosis or
meaning really reading x-ray scans what
you can do is take this loss output
layer of the neural network and just
delete that and delete also the waste
feeding into that loss output layer and
create a new set of randomly initialized
ways just for the last layer and at that
now output radiology diagnosis so to be
concrete during the first phase of
training when you're trading on an image
recognition task you train all of the
usual parameters within your network all
the ways all the layers and you have
something that now learns to make image
recognition predictions having trained
that neural network what you now do to
implement transfer learning is swap in a
new data set X Y where now these are
radiology images and why are the
diagnosis you want to predict and what
you do is initialize the last layers
ways is called a WL + BL random being
and now we train the neural network on
this new data set on the new radiology
dataset
we have a couple options of hajji
regions in your network with radiology
data you might if you have a small
radiology data set you might want to
just retrain the weights of the last
layer just W LPL and keep the rest of
parameters fixed if you have an up data
you could also retrain all the layers of
the rest of the neural network and the
rule of thumb is maybe a bit of a small
data set then just retrain the one loss
layer at the output layer or maybe even
lost one or two layers there's a lot of
data then maybe you can retrain all the
parameters in the networks and if you
retrain all the parameters in your
network then this initial phase of
training on image recognition is
sometimes called pre training because
you're using image recognition data to
pre initialize or really pre train the
weights of the neural network and then
if you are updating all the ways
afterwards and trading on the radiology
data sometimes that's called fine tuning
so if you share the words pre training
and fine tuning in a deep learning
context this is what they mean when they
refer to pre training and fine tuning
ways in a transfer learning cost and
what you've done in this example is
you've taken knowledge learn from image
recognition and applied it or
transferred it to radiology diagnosis
and the reason this can be helpful is
that a lot of the low-level features
such as detecting edges that encourage
detecting positive objects learning from
that from a very enlarged image
recognition data set might help your
learning algorithm do better in
radiology diagnosis it's just learned a
lot about the structure and the nature
of how images look like and some of that
knowledge will be useful so having learn
to recognize images it might have
learned enough about you know just what
parts of different images look like that
that knowledge about lines dots curves
and so on may be small parts of objects
that knowledge could help your radiology
diagnosis Network learn a bit faster or
learn what less data here's another
example let's say that you've trained a
speech recognition
so now X is inputs of audio or your
snippers and Y is some in transcript so
you're trained in speech recognition
system to output your transcripts and
let's say that you now want to build a
waik word or a trigger word detection
system so recall that they wake whether
the trigger words are the words we say
in order to wake up speech control
devices in the houses such as saying
Alexis and we're going Amazon echo or
okay Google to waken Google device or a
series with an Apple device or saying
they hope I do to wake up up my to
device so in order to do this you might
take out the last layer of the neural
network again and create a new output
note but sometimes another thing you
could do is actually create not just a
single new output but actually create
several new layers to your neural
network to try to predict the labels Y
for your wake word detection problem
then again depending on how much data
you have you might just retrain the new
layers of the network or maybe you could
be trained you're even more layers of
this neural network so when does
transfer learning makes sense transfer
learning makes sense when you have a lot
of data for the problem you're
transferring from and usually relatively
less data for the problem you're
transferring to so for example let's say
you have a million examples for your
image recognition tasks so that's a lot
of data to learn a lot of low-level
features or to learn a lot of useful
features in the earlier layers in your
network but for the radiology tasks
maybe you have only 100 examples so
you're very low data for the radiology
diagnosis problem you have only 100
x-ray scans so lot of knowledge you
learn from image recognition can be
transferred and can really help you get
going with radiology recognition even if
you don't have an all the data for
radiology
or speech recognition maybe you've
trained the speech recognition system on
$10,000 of data so you have learned a
lot about what human voices sounds like
from that $10,000 of data which really
is a lot but for your trigger word
detection maybe you have only one hour
of data so that's not raw data to figure
out parameters so in this case a lot of
what you learn about what human voices
sound like what are components of human
speech and so on that can be really
helpful but building a good wake word
detector even though you have a
relatively small data center he's a much
smaller data set for the weak word
detection task so both of these cases
are transferring from a problem with a
lot of data to a problem with relatively
little data one case where transfer
learning would not make sense is if the
opposite was true so if you had a
hundred images for image recognition and
you had a hundred images for radiology
diagnosis or even you're a thousand
images really for radiology diagnosis
one would think about it is that to do
well on radiology diagnosis assuming
what you really want to do well on is
radiology diagnosis having radiology
images is much more valuable than having
cat-and-dog and so on images so each
example here is much more valuable than
each example there at least for the
purpose of building a good radiology
system so if you already have more data
for radiology is not that likely that
having 100 images or your random objects
of cats and dogs and calls and so on
would be that helpful because the value
of one example of images from your
English recognition terms of cats and
dogs is just less valuable than one
example of an x-ray image for the task
of building a good radiology system so
this would be one example where transfer
learning well it might not hurt but I
wouldn't expect it to give you any
meaningful gain either and similarly if
you built a speech recognition system on
10oz of data and you actually have 10
hours or maybe even more say 50 hours of
data for week word detection you know it
won't merely not hurt maybe it won't
hurt to include that 10 hours of data to
do transfer
but you just couldn't expect to get a
meaningful game
so to summarize when does transfer
learning make sense if you're trying to
learn from some task a and transfer some
of the knowledge to sometimes be then
transfer learning make sense when toss a
and B have the same input X in the first
example a and B both images as input in
the second example both had audio codes
as input it tends to make sense when you
have one more data for toss a then toss
B all this is under the assumption that
what you really want to do well on this
toss video and because data for tossed B
is more valuable for toss B usually you
just need a lot more data for toss a
because do each example from toss a is
just less valuable photos B in each
example for toss B and then finally
transfer learning will tend to make more
sense if you suspect that low-level
features from toss a could be helpful
for learning times B and in both of the
earlier examples maybe learning image
recognition teaches you a number about
images to hover radiology diagnosis and
maybe learning speech recognition
teaches you about human speech to help
you with trigger words on record
detection so to summarize transfer
learning tends to be most useful if
you're trying to do well on sometimes be
usually a problem where you're
relatively little data so for example in
radiology you know difficult to get that
many x-ray scans to build a good
radiology diagnosis system so in that
case you might find it related by
different tasks such as image
recognition where you can get maybe
million images and learn a lot of
low-level features from that so that you
can then try to do well on toss be on
your radiology task despite not having
damage data for it
when transfer learning makes sense it
does help the performance of your
learning algorithms significantly but
I've also seen sometimes seen transfer
learning applied in settings where toss
a actually has less data than toss B and
in those cases you kind of don't expect
to see much of a game
so that's it's a transfer learning where
you learn from one toss and try to
transfer to a different task there's
another version of learning from
multiple toss which is called
multitasking which is when you try to
learn from multiple tasks at the same
time rather than learning from one and
then sequentially or after that trying
to transfer to a different task so in
the next video let's discuss
multitasking